hallo mein name ist luca rentabel und
herzlich willkommen doch heute mal
wieder zu ich hab's vergessen zu ändern
wir schauen uns heute mal wieder einige
ebay kleinanzeigen fels an allerdings
keine fails im sinne von komische
angebote rechtschreibfehler keine ahnung
was sondern chats das hier ist der erste
jet und zwar verkaufte jemand ein iphone
die personen die das iphone kaufen will
schreibt zwei euro nur handy okay also
er bietet dem verkäufer zwei euro für
ein iphone an da kann man auch endlich
mal klatschen daraufhin schreibt der
verkäufer was nur handy handy tauschen
tauschen gegen s8 also der verkäufer
denkt dass der käufer das iphone was er
verkauft tauschen will auf den streik
der käufer wieder nokia mit tasten und
zwei euro ok dollar mittags ist besser
als diese iphone
wer kennt sich den neuen iphone machen
allerdings direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten ebay feld und zwar verkaufte
jemand eine mütze
ihr seht schon der käufer fragt ob er
sie auch für 1 euro 15 kaufen kann die
mitte steht allerdings im ebay
kleinanzeigen für zwei euro drin
deswegen schreibt der verkäufer nein tut
mir leid die mütze ist neu und deshalb
möchte ich schon gerne noch zwei euro
dafür haben die antwort vom käufer
daraufhin ist dubaier ja da kann ich ihm
tatsächlich recht geben
er verkauft in die mütze für zwei euro
alter der verlauf ist wieder so richtig
richtig bescheuert jemand verkaufte ein
bett und ein möglicher käufer schreibt
ist in diesem bett schon jemand
gestorben daraufhin schreibt der
verkäufer nein ich ziehe aus und habe
ein neues der potenzielle käufer
schreibt dann wiederum wie viele leute
passen in diese bett daraufhin bekommt
er die antwort ein bis zwei die matratze
ist ein mieter 40 breit dann fragt er
noch ist flecken auf matratze welches
daraufhin antwortet der verkäufer nein
dann nichts für mich
er sucht also eine matratze mit flecken
ja okay hier verkauft jemand eine hose
auf ebay und der mögliche käufer fragt
hallo haben sie die hose auch in größe
48 liebe grüße daraufhin schreibt der
verkäufer guten abend tut mir leid nein
ich verkaufe nur dieser eine hose der
fragensteller zeigt sich dementsprechend
kooperativ und
sich schreibt ich verstehe arschloch
super wie freundlich die leute da sind
zwar allerdings direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten kinofilm zwar verkaufte man ein
iphone 6 mit 64 gigabyte daraufhin
schreibt einkäufer ich kaufe sofort wenn
sie zeit haben können sie jetzt kommen
wenn sie können mich kommen ich bezahle
360 meine nummer ist können sie jetzt
kommen können sie jetzt er macht also
ordentlich druck und daraufhin schreibt
der verkäufer sorry handy wurde
anderweitig reserviert auf in cannes
einfach nur die nachricht dass es unfair
ja das wäre fällig auch und fernseher
verkauft jemand einen audi q7 also einen
audi geländewagen daraufhin schreibt
einkäufer tauschen sie auch gegen einen
rasen trecker kann in lisdorf abgeholt
werden er will also einen audi q7 nicht
kaufen sondern tauschen gegen einen
track alles klare verkäufer schreibt
daraufhin sehr geehrte damen und herren
wenn ich das richtig verstehe wollen sie
einen rasen trecker gegen einen 16 1999
euro teures auto tauschen und wir sollen
den trecker abholen würde daraufhin
fragt der verkäufer ist der aus gold
nein das rot
allerdings nun zudem wie ich finde
dieser folge mit bescheuerten ebay chat
feld und zwar verkaufte jemand einen bmw
der käufer fragt 10.500 bzw er schreibt
einfach 10.500 verkäufe antwortet
daraufhin einfach ok daraufhin der
mögliche käufer wieder ja oder nein
10.500 komme morgen abholen also er
beschließt einfach schon dass er das
ding einfach abholen wird auch sie
wollen den bmw 14.500 euro kaufen das
tut mir leid das habe ich nicht
verstanden da stand noch eine zahl um
nein für den preis bleiben sie lieber zu
hause also der verkäufer zeigt hiermit
ganz klar hey das ist mir zu wenig geld
die antwort von den möglichen käufer ist
darauf hin dass freundlich du [ __ ]
da würde ich mir dann darüber überlegen
ob ich an dem vielleicht doch verkaufen
würde hier verkauft die man einen
kühlschrank und bekommt direkt die
nachricht von einem möglichen käufer 40
euro also direkt ein angebot das
günstiger ist als das was er eigentlich
für das für den kühlschrank haben möchte
daraufhin schreibt der einfachen 1 50
euro ok ok 50 euro kommen sofort nein
nein ich fand diese ebay kleinanzeigen
angebots sales ja schon mega meist als
habe ich auch schon fünf sechs videos
hochgeladen rola fast mehr
aber diese chips setzen dem ganzen an
dummheit wirklich noch was oben drauf
also das ist wahnsinn auch hier der
nächste letzte preis bitte wenig selber
abholen er antwortet hallo 115 euro 80
euro kann ich auch selber abholen 80
euro können sie auch zu hause bleiben
sie haben meine gefühle verletzt er ist
aber auch egal ich glaube ich muss auch
gar nicht verstehen wie die leute auf
die ganzen nachrichten kommen und warum
sie dann solche komischen sachen
schreiben
allerdings habe ich euch ja vor einigen
videos bereits dieses neue pocket
vorgestellt das am 16.9 launischen wird
und heute möchte ich euch das zweite der
fünf neuen produkte zeigen die wie
bereits gesagt am 16 um 15 uhr im lukas
ott launischen werden und zwar ist es
dieses t shirt und nein das ist kein
produktionsfehler falls es irgendwelche
komiker denken das sind zwei
verschiedene stoffe zusammengenäht zu
einem t shirt und wir haben hier die
haben wir vorher drauf und hier ganz
normalen prinz wer es geht super einher
mit unserem kollektions gedanken den
werde ich euch demnächst vorstellen wenn
ich alle fünf produkte in einem video
nochmal gesondert vorstellen werde aber
das hier ist auf jeden fall auch ein
shirt was am ersten sechs neue lounge
inn wird im koeln.de
ich habe mich gefragt warum es noch
frauen parfüm riecht aber das war jude
das an hatte naja freunde das eben ganz
kurz noch mal ein wenig informationen
bezüglich erster 6 lukas weise das hier
sind schon mal zwei produkte die er
mittlerweile dann schon kennt die neuen
werden am ersten sechs aber wir machen
jetzt weiter mit dem nächsten abi chat
verlaufen der hat es definitiv in sich
hier schreibt eine person mit einem
anderen ebay user namens sascha und zwar
schreibt dieser sascha hallo für 70 euro
würde ich das handy heute holen
der typ der das handy verkauft schreibt
für 100 euro kann es gerne abgeholt
werden als er will 30 euro mehr haben
daraufhin antwortet der sascha ganz
stumpf für 100 darfst du mir einen
blasen
du bist das ist du bist wirklich dritter
wahrscheinlich sind deine eltern nicht
zu finden mit und auch der nächste die
wirtschaft verlauf meine lieben
zuschauer hat es komplett in sich und
zwar schreibt jemand hallo ist das bett
noch zu haben
also da verkauft ihm in ein bett er
fragt freundlich nach ist das bett noch
zu haben er bekommt die antwort hallo
leider nicht mehr ich habe vergessen
dass rauszunehmen mache ich sofort lg
ist auch eine ganz freundliche antwort
darauf an schreibt die person wieder
okay
super sonst lag ich dich
ich weiß nicht wie man auf so eine
scheiße kommt oder auch dieser ebay
freude ich kann wirklich nicht welche
verkauft jemand ein ferngesteuertes auto
der käufer schreibt geiles gerät er
schreibt interesse
ich meinte dass in meiner hose warum
warum war also wirklich warum auch bei
diesem ebay freude ich kann wirklich
nicht mehr hier schreibt jemand er sucht
einen gitarristen daraufhin schreibt ein
möglicher gitarrist anja anscheinend
hallo ich möchte abholen
der verkäufer in dem fall also derjenige
der den gitarristen sucht schreibt haben
sie verstanden worum es in dieser
anzeige geht sein
hallo guten tag ich habe in der asse das
fahrrad wie kostet mit freundlich grüßen
mehr match das ist die nachricht in
dieser ebay user hier geschrieben hat
daraufhin bekommt er die antwort wie
viel würdest du denn zahlen daraufhin
schreibt der mehmet hinten felge caputh
besser verschenken geben
als er würde gar nichts sagen möchte es
einfach geschenkt bekommen gute taktik
märz nächstes verkaufte jemand ein apple
iphone 7 und bekommt daraufhin die
fragen von dem verkäufer hallo noch da
wo kann ich es abholen daraufhin
schreibt der verkäufer des handys hallo
ja alles noch da wir können gerne einen
treffpunkt vereinbaren da wäre ich
flexibel daraufhin schreibt dann
allerdings der käufer haben sie kein
zuhause würde mir echt mal gerne die
leute hinter diesen nachrichten
anschauen 2000 euro nein war ein musst
du ja sagen
2000 euro nein ich sage ja ich laufe
wieder nur klatschen durch mein zimmer
alter haben wir allerdings nur noch zum
letzten major heute meine damen und
herren ich weiß ich weiß es tut mir leid
die folge schon wieder vorbei thomas
maar um jux aber im endeffekt niemand
hier verkauft jemand sein iphone cdu
bekommt einen gegenangebot von einem
anderen ebay user und zwar matratze zwei
meter mal 2 meter neupreis 950.000 er
will also seine matratze gegen das
iphone tauschen
der verkäufer des iphones fragt schenkst
du mir die daraufhin der andere mit der
matratze ja wenn du mir das iphone
schenkst er bekommt dann allerdings die
antwort im traum was soll ich mit einer
durchgenudelt matratze chicago wahnsinn
richtig an der stelle würde ich auch
einfach nur noch sagen
[Musik]